Sharon was upbeat smiling at a nail
salon in Beverly Hills yesterday two
days after the actress was granted a
temporary restraining order against a 55
year old alleged stalker a judge okayed
after the man said he's set to be
released from prison in four months in
the document Sharon says she became
terrified after he bombarded her with
letters from the psychiatric ward in one
of those letters
she says he asked her to bring him quote
to Crown Royal bags full of diamonds
Mike - CIA badges twenty billion dollars
worth of Department of Treasury checks
she also cites another letter quote I
have 11 wives picked out and would cause
about 18 kids you would sit at the other
head of the dining table et today with
Rhonda Saunders an international
consultant on stalking and former
prosecutor I think the comments that he
has been making in the letters to Sharon
Stone about the dinner about having
diamonds all of these other riches he is
delusional and just because someone is
in prison or in a mental hospital it
doesn't mean that they're getting any
treatment whatsoever here's the timeline
of Sharon's legal battle with the
alleged stalker in 2011 she filed a
restraining order against the man for
quote showing up twice uninvited at her
home in 2013 that restraining order
expired
what do you mean what's the matter made
a lot of money for you I want my cut
stone is best known for her roles in
casino and Basic Instinct
she's also committed to social cause